he's being to you welcome to the Dean
show an amazing show for you today
winter my martial arts Bruce Lee Gracie
the legendary family that rocked the
world we're going to be talking about
these exciting exciting things and more
we talk bullying and epidemic today
we're going to be talking about dieting
giving you some great tips here with the
family that started the Ultimate
Fighting Championships built it from the
beginning from scratch all of that and
more with Henner
Gracie will be trying to give you a
bonus also now to break dance butter a
break down all of this and more here on
the D show don't go anywhere
this is the this is the pain you know
this is the days of the theme this is
the theme the vault of the Bible are you
coming aren't you
thanks for having me man how you been
amazing that I'm excited to be here I've
heard about the Dean show I've seen
other interviews and I always wondered
if I would get the invite I'm excited
that you accepted invitation thank you
for being with my pleasure mail time
time is short
you heard me open the show we mentioned
Bruce Lee the great seat yeah we're
tapping into a market the Dean show
thank out is viewed internationally all
over the globe and some people still
they don't know right I know you know
definitely so some people we mentioned
Bruce Lee now yeah I was growing up to
Bruce Lee most of us we love Bruce Lee I
even went to elementary school I think
in eighth grade I put there like the
kung-fu Sudan I was so high that was it
so so let's talk a little bit let's
introduce the people now they think man
you know what Bruce Lee this guy'll kill
anybody who just dominate but now we got
Helio Gracie and the Gracie family
let's get them as foes talk to us yeah
it's definitely um you know people is -
one of the most common questions I get
you know as a member of this Gracie
family is who would have one Bruce or Lu
Bruce or voice Bruce Hicks on Bruce know
anybody and I think it's just a
different era you know there's no doubt
and I think that not to take anything
away from Bruce Bruce is a very
dedicated martial artisan like like the
Gracie family he's very dedicated to
taking what works and disregarding what
does it and in that sense we're very
similar but if you ask me Bruce in his
prime and any Gracie in their prime the
Gracie jiu-jitsu has the advantage
simply because Bruce would need to
remain standing and striking whereas the
Gracie family would want to close the
distance take him to the ground unless
he got that one punch or one kick
knockout and he goes to the ground he
then he's in our territory you know at
that point he would use a lot of energy
waste his energy and he get choked out
but we would let go and would be friends
after and
would learn jujitsu after that's the
funny part he's open-minded yes see I'm
gonna play the skeptic because I know
but some people don't so they'll just
say like look Bruce Lee would have just
been at 101 punch 1 kick he's done and
the truth is you know we never had a
chance to test jutsu against Bruce but
we've tested you two against every other
striking discipline and and and in
mastery form of martial art that you
could possibly imagine and all of them
felt the same way
thirty years of Taekwondo 30 years of
boxing 15 20 years of kickboxing and
they felt they can get that perfect
punch or kick the problem is in order
for the perfect punch or kick to land I
have to be right here at this range I
have to be one arm length away from you
so what does the Gracie do stands two
arm lengths away two arms away where the
punches don't reach so what does the
striker do I have to get closer to hit
him but when the striker gets closer to
hit you and you grab them you're now
mess up their distance so the striker
has one chance out of a hundred to knock
us out we have ninety nine chances out
of 100 to grab ahold of their clothing
their body and pull them in and if we
grab them it's over because the date the
distance is no longer there for the
punch my grandfather always said this in
a fight whoever manages the distance
manages the damage that can be done so
if we stay away and then we grab them
it's a done deal
amazingamazing now this was proven this
is not a theory no he's not theory and
that's where your family came eighty
five years your father how's he doing
amazing having kids living the life
chillin retirement let him mean he don't
run the show and he's very relaxed like
to say hello to your father
man yes to the family and we really are
grateful and thankful for this you know
this martial art really I got addicted
as soon as I came in had a met had a
small guy literally like 130 pounds I
went into at the time we were the
representatives for the Gracie Academy
right here in Chicago and I was just
really into working out I did a lot of
stand-up martial arts you know I used to
like to throw punches and then it was
all about the bench press who could ask
for worse you know on top of court went
in there small guy got me tired locked
my arm boom addicted done all had you
had to respect it cuz it worked and and
this is the the UFC yeah proved at all
talk about your family started this year
for ya cuz my family had been testing it
when the UFC
was created in 1993 for 65 years prior
to that my family had already been
testing jiu-jitsu against other
disciplines of martial arts so we
already knew jiu-jitsu had a superior
you know superior skills for a real
street fight so it had been tested
successfully for so many years that my
dad just said well if we can put this on
television then we'll be able to answer
the most important question of them all
which system of self defense is most
effective when there are no rules no
time limits no judges no points nothing
the two men go in one man walks out and
really be able to test once and for all
what really works and I think that you
know we accomplished that because you
have Siwon for any of you out there
who've never seen you know the original
UFC is you have to go back UFC one two
three and four are the main ones because
each fighter in that situation
represented a discipline and it was
wrestling versus karate boxing versus
jiu-jitsu savate versus sumo this is
amazing stuff and you get a chance to
really see in a raw setting what really
works and what does it from the best
representatives my dad was very clever
he knew that of all the eight
representatives of all the martial
artists he wanted to put the jiu-jitsu
representative to be the smallest one
the physically smallest and weakest one
so that when hoist the representative
from our family would go in there and
defeat these giants people would not be
able to attribute his success to his
physical attributes and when he defeated
them which he did people said wow if the
little skinny Brazilian guy can beat the
Giants that's what I want to learn so
basically it was a big demonstration of
the effectiveness of jiu-jitsu and it
worked perfectly thank God hoist one
because who knows where we'd be if he
didn't and and that was it man haven't
put you two on the map 1993 that went
down 1994 US Army contacted our family
and think then the US Army has been
practicing jiu-jitsu as part of their
basic combatives training 1.2 million
soldiers now adopted jiu-jitsu it's
amazing it's amazing amazing definitely
and anyone I know who's incorporated
into their life even if they've trained
30 years and other martial right I mean
they amend ously benefit what about the
person who says look look look look the
martial art that we do is to Dudley yeah
my next guest is so dangerous of
body that we have a paramedic standing
by you can't be tested because we tested
somebody might end up dead have you
heard these yeah we've heard that and
you know and and and and they all
generally change their mind once they
get choked out and they wake up from the
choke and they say wow that was that was
pretty amazing because these guys they
can't fight in the UFC but they can come
to the Academy and they can have a
challenge match which they did for the
last 65 7 years this happened where guys
would come in and we would say listen
you do what you do whether that's
headbutt groin strikes you want to do
that I gouge whatever you want you do
what you do we do what we do and we'll
fight so let's not get it twisted people
have come and tested these deadly
techniques all to to to no avail and and
jiu-jitsu has prevailed again it doesn't
matter what it is they need a certain
distance they need access to my face and
if I'm blocking and managing the
distance correctly the destruction that
and the technique simply don't work how
about this aren't well you can't even
grab the guy and he's like 20 guys are
coming at him he's doing some stuff
people just falling he can actually put
you out without even touching you
without even touching them using energy
to interfere with their nervous system
please welcome the man with the fingers
of death Fred I can't wait to learn that
one amazing amazing we're gonna take a
break header let's do it and we'll be
right back with more here on the Dean
show what are we doing here and where
are we gonna go it's like we just woke
up one morning and then it's welcome to
the show don't ask any questions just go
with the flow make as much money as you
can and try your best not to get broke
copy everything you see on the TV from
the hairstyles to the clothes and don't
think too often just do exactly as
you're told and if you ever get confused
and just turn towards the alcohol you
still hear thoughts then just turn up
the radio as you learn to live a
lifestyle of drugs sex and rock and roll
but in all honesty I just need to know
is there more to the cycle than growing
and getting old living and dying just to
leave behind a happy home and a whole
lot of property that somebody else is
going to own I just really need to know
before the caskets closed because I'm
not willing to gamble with my soul nor
am I ready to take any chances these are
just simple life questions and I'm just
searching for some answers like what are
we doing here and what is our purpose
how did we get here and who made us so
perfect and what happens once we go or
is this world or really worth it
questions we don't answer because
apparently we don't really have to
there's no purpose to this life and our
existence is merely natural then in that
case please let me ask you did you
create yourself or was it somebody else
who had fashioned you cuz you're a being
that's impeccable faultless and
unparalleled you're a product of supreme
intelligence and I'm merely being
rational for there isn't a camera on
this earth that can come close to the
human eye nor a computer that can
compete alongside the human mind and if
the whole world was to come together we
wouldn't be able to create a single fly
so many signs yet we still deny the
science tries to justify that all this
could come from none when it's a simple
sum zero plus zero plus zero cannot
possibly ever give you one so from where
did all this order come for everything
has its origins a maker a creator of its
own I mean the only reason you're
watching this video is because somebody
had to press upload so we can believe in
the Big Bang but I'd rather believe
then he who caused it to explode Allah
the creator of everything along with
every single soul the everliving the
master the only one who is in control
unlike his creation beyond our
imagination and no he's not a man nor
does he have any partners in association
he's on his own and though he did not
ever leave us alone
just like every manufacturer he left us
with an instruction manual the Koran and
the slam and I'm sorry to jump to
conclusions but it's the only one
possible the only definition of God is
the one and only Supreme Being its
logical a book with zero contradictions
with miracles that are both scientific
and historical or revealed over 1400
years ago like the detailed description
of the human embryo the descriptions of
the human embryo in the Quran cannot be
based on scientific knowledge in the
seventh and - the mountains as pegs
holding firm the earth below and the two
seas that don't mix in a complete
separate flow to the planets in orbit
alternating night and day as they stay
in flow the expansion of the universe
and the creation of everything from h2o
to the stories of the past and the
preservation of Pharaoh to identifying
the lowest point in the land where
Persia defeated Rome the gushing fluid
that created man in the glands between
the ribs and the backbone and not a word
has changed is still the same so please
explain how all this was known over 1400
years ago to a man who couldn't read or
write as he would recite whatever the
angel spoke and if you still don't
believe please try to come up with
something that's even close but you
can't so we took God as a mockery and
his messy
is a joke dismiss these scriptures as
legends and tales of the ancient folk as
we live life according to our whims
desires and hopes saying this life is
the only home we will ever know we will
lift and dive and simply turn to bones
yo lo correction after the grass dies
the rain arrives and it regrows and
Allah promises to do the same thing to
your very soul and bring you back from
your very fingertips to your toes as the
all-seeing Supreme Being watches us so
close and we are surely being tested in
our wealth our health and our self and
everything that we've been blessed with
so believed for we will surely be
resurrected and be brought back to our
Lord in a calper every single deed as he
hands us our books and orders us to read
from the badge that our good and
everything in between
you yourself is sufficient for your own
accountability so don't be mad at me you
are the one who thought he wouldn't come
back to me I gave you a whole life long
to search after me but you were busy in
all that which was temporary so read and
glad tidings to all those who believed
and if you disbelieve read and don't let
that day be the first day you find out
what your life really means read
back here on the Dean show with Henner
Gracie your family started built the UFC
Ultimate Fighting Championship who can
we say without a doubt without a shadow
of a doubt that gracie brazilian
jiu-jitsu is the most effective proven
the most effective martial art in the
world on the planet no doubt no doubt
III think that nowadays we have a lot of
people who are merging different
disciplines and practicing multiple arts
which is a great thing as well but when
you when you really you know sort them
out there's no doubt that jiu-jitsu our
judges who has the most proven track
record in real combat against other
disciplines so that being said if you
had to choose something to practice juzu
is the best place to start I mean again
I'm testifying to that because I used to
box
stand up kick box and when I
incorporated it was all about you know
just throwing the punch and you know you
get your hands broken you know
head-butting it's so soft it's it's it's
like a a jujitsu disorder - it's such a
gentle way to subdue someone you don't
even have to hurt them and that's the
thing that I think that it's an aspect
that a lot of people a lot of humane
individuals really appreciate about it
because not every altercation you
encounter with someone who tries to
either offend you or an uncle who gets
too drunk at a family gathering and is
acting ridiculous and you have to
control this person not every situation
warrants ripping someone's eyes out of
their sockets you know what I'm saying
so to have the technique and have a
system of self-defense that gives you
the full range of options in dealing
with some whether it be just
neutralization holds where you can just
control someone against their will until
they decide to cooperate or you know
deadly techniques where I can break
someone's joints or kill someone if I
have to just gives you the full range
and I think that's what people
appreciate the most about it because a
lot of times ask someone you know you
should learn jujitsu and then why don't
you and they say well I'm a lover not a
fighter and that's the worst answer
possible because my response to them is
if you're really a lover then you should
learn jujitsu because only then can you
control your drunk uncle without hurting
them at the kid's birthday party because
if you don't know [ __ ] - what are you
going to do punch his face in are tend
to be a bloody brawl but wish your [ __ ]
- no blood no cuts no nothing crazy just
control which ties into our Gracie
bully-proof anti-bullying program the
non-violence aspect
what I was going to get into next we
know that millions of kids are bullied
each year hundreds of thousand they
refused sometimes to even go to class to
squirt lemon tell us about this program
that you guys do to help empower
children yes they can prevent major
because we grew up in the Gracie family
very fortunate you know all around my
uncles and my dad and my grandfather
learning how to defend myself from as
early as I can walk I'm learning
self-defense not every kid had that
opportunity so for us when my brother
and I grew up and we mature and we
finally took over the Gracie Academy it
was our belief that if we could create a
program that would give families the
opportunity and the resources to prepare
their children the same way my brothers
and I were prepared from an early age we
would be doing a great service for the
world for a referred meant for mankind
and we went for it we created the Gracie
bully-proof at-home training program
where on DVD or online someone can have
the exact lessons that our father put us
through from the beginning and it starts
with Gracie games they learn how to play
jiu-jitsu they don't even know they're
learning self-defense and they're
learning the principles of control and
movement and closeness and distance
management and once they get that basic
foundation then they learn the rules of
engagement we teach them when they can
and when they can't use these techniques
in self-defense once they understand
that that side of things then we start
teaching them what's called junior
grappler junior combatives and these
techniques are the self defense
thirty-three techniques basically that
they'll need for any self-defense
situation on school grounds on the way
home from school to defend against a
larger attacker and the best part at
least that I've gotten feedback from
parents around the world the best part
is the non-violence aspect because if
you take if you if you have a kid who's
getting bullied and you take him to
boxing class or a karate class and you
say hey go learn some punches and kicks
that child's only resource to aggression
or harassment is going to be the punch
and kick aggressor in the face and
you're turning the victim into the bully
in that case so for us it's not about
fighting fire with more fire it's
teaching the children how to fight fire
with water if an aggressor comes we
teach them how to first neutralize it
verbally verbals your Jitsu if that
doesn't work you have to get help
tell a teacher tell a parent tell a
grown-up if that doesn't work and the
aggressor still is attacking them then
they can defend themselves with
techniques but only two
match the level of aggression coming so
just enough to put out the fire but no
more and that's the secret and in that
sense we're creating more respectful
discipline tolerant and confident more
importantly than anything else young
boys and girls and we're going to go to
a clip right now and then we're gonna
come back it's really it's sad to see
something like this but we want the
audience to see really the reality of
what's going on in some of these schools
and we get your thoughts on let's do it
watch as a 15 year old classmate in the
white t-shirt slams Austin to the ground
and punches him relentlessly I just saw
that heartbreaking clip you see that I
mean the kid would just attacked and
just beaten tell us your thoughts on it
well yeah this is uh this is Austin
McDaniel this happened in Indiana last
year October November and some you know
him oh yeah well yeah so we've since had
a chance to Train Austin and Austin was
beat up and someone sent me this video
and you know it's it's sad because every
time I see a video like this because you
can imagine how many cases like this are
not recorded by school security cameras
99% are not caught on camera so to have
a chance to see this reminds us of the
of the bowling epidemic that we're
dealing with here in the United States
and it inspired me to do something
because I knew I could help Austin so I
reached out to his family and
fortunately they accepted the Gracie
Academy offer to come to Torrance where
we actually spent a week training Austin
and ultimately empowering him with to
physical self-defense techniques and the
psychological and the verbal jujitsu
techniques we sent him back after a week
and I can say this he wasn't the same
kid basically we transformed him from
the inside out and he'll never have this
problem again for the rest of his life
and if you care to see the actual the
documentary of his week with us it's on
it's on YouTube Austin McDaniels
one-week transformation we know that I
mean this this is something that like we
said it's an epidemic it's really scary
so you believe firmly that now when a
kid like Austin he went through this
program now he's really into our yeah
you know and he's able to you know
defuse a situation you know through
verbally or also now if things and again
yeah and you know what it is is a lot of
people stable one week come on how is
that possible well I can tell you how
it's possible
we had to reprogram Austin in that sense
that he was programmed from very young
age and this is a result of society his
parents and his family to believe that
you cannot be firm confident powerful
and strong and outspoken while at the
same time be respectful courteous humble
loving caring individual he thought
those two were mutually exclusive
they're not we taught him to say no you
can be respectful humble courteous and
still be firm confident strong and
assertive with yourself that's what we
change in a week
this kid is 511 210 pounds he's a big
boy and very athletic you know I'm
saying very cool kid we met him as your
Teddy Sonoma hung out with him all week
what he didn't believe is he could be
both once we showed him some techniques
nonviolent jiu-jitsu and we convinced
him through these techniques in our
connection that he could do whatever he
wants with his with his strength it
changed everything he went home knowing
that he's allowed to assert himself when
she ever had permission to do that
amazing amazing let's go a little bit to
how important is it when you want we've
all watched Karate Kid wax on right hand
backs off left hand yeah Miyagi very you
see really he taught Daniel some some
some really good ethics and some work
discipline good character he was really
breeding him then you got called acai
right kill kill crazy you know and we
see that in the martial arts world we
see like we've gone away from integrity
good character when you come in for
instance to our Academy on the wall you
see the best among you are those who
have the best character the best manners
how important is this to in Marsh and to
be a complete martial artist well it's
huge because you know how important is
it for a police officer to have
integrity you give a police officer a
gun a baton and a Taser and you say go
and force the law if that police officer
has those with tools and those weapons
and does not have the integrity to the
equal degree you're you're putting out a
very dangerous individual to society and
martial arts the exact same thing we
talk about oh you know my hands are
registered weapons in 48 states and I'll
eat the weapon in blah blah blah I have
tools that can do some serious damage
we give students those tools but we make
sure at the same time to give the
integrity the humility and the the
knowledge of when they are allowed to be
used and to what degree and and and how
they have to control their their
ultimately how they use these weapons
very important I was going to throw this
in earlier because you mentioned someone
when you talk to him about training I'm
a lover not a fighter
now another one that I've heard how do
you answer this when you you're really
excited to get someone to come and
experience it so now you start talking
to him he said look man if someone says
something to me I just take am I gonna
just blast them yeah yes it's pretty
common it's like I'm all set
I know what do you say to this where's
your gun right now you got it on they go
no not right now
I say okay you're screwed thing you know
we're gonna do so the bottom line is you
don't always have a gun with you number
one this is easy answers number two is
not every situation warrants shooting
someone in the face you know what I'm
saying like you like I said the drunk
uncle situation or you know an
ex-boyfriend or the liability that comes
with hurting someone beyond the call of
duty we don't even want to go that route
but the point is everyone would like to
have the ability to defend themselves
against a giant with nothing but their
bare hands anyone who says otherwise is
lying to you now if that's the truth
then why aren't they embarking on the
journey fear of the unknown and people
out there who think you two might be for
them and are fascinated by these
discussions but have not made moves in
that direction what you have to do is
check out Gracie University calm we
created this website specifically for
people who either a don't live near a
qualified Academy like the red civic
brothers here in Chicago or the Gracie
Academy in Torrance or any one of our
certified training centers hey they live
too far from a school or be they live
really close to a school but they're too
nervous about what's going to go on in
the school when they get there so you go
to Gracie University you watch the first
five lessons for free and you get to see
what jiu-jitsu is and how the learning
takes place and if you love what you see
online you can either learn there or
come visit my friends here and embark on
the journey with another without an
entire group of like-minded people who
are also on that path to jiu-jitsu
mastery and personal mastery at the same
time we're going to be right back with
one more session here with Hannah Gracie
few more questions and we might even get
you to do a little breakdown come on bro
we'll be right back here
Dean show is your boss driving a crazy
are you just living from paycheck to
paycheck party to party and everything
is just getting tiring it's getting
played out and you're asking yourself
what's this all about
what's the purpose many people don't
reflect like I mean why am I here you're
born to die and then what do you got in
between me it's a big drama some days
are good some days are bad some days
you're sick some days you're sad we not
you might not make it to 85 years old we
might not make it till tomorrow and this
is something that we need to think about
the lights will go on after the party
and the party will end and you will be
alone and you will have to be
accountable for everything you've done
life is not all about just chasing that
man or woman or that good time it's not
all about the baseball game in the
basketball game and chasing a position
and getting a lot of wealth and money
there's more to this life and it's up to
you to be sincere enough within yourself
and to want to know more what's the
purpose what's it all about like it's
simple to understand Islam means
submission look at the word submission
not to yourself not to your desires not
to anyone or anything because at the end
of the day you get something you always
want more you get some weed you want
more you get some drugs you want harder
drugs
you get aggro you want a nicer girl you
get a car you want a nicer car you get
out on a nicer house we've got so many
pressures by enslaving yourself
worshiping God loving God but submission
to the one who created you and by
worshipping going and seeking his
pleasure you get pleased and you enter
then god bless you
to move equally I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone if
Allah is by my side I am Not Afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone I am not afraid to stand alone if
Allah is by my side I am Not Afraid to
stand alone I am Not Afraid to stand
alone
if Allah is by my side I am not afraid
to stand alone
I am Not Afraid to stand alone if allies
by my side I am not afraid to stand
alone if Allah is by my side I am not
afraid to stand alone I am not afraid to
stand alone
if allies by my side I am not afraid to
stand
back here on the Dean show of Henner
Gracie how's your brother here on oh man
is great he has a baby daughter he don't
has a six-month-old baby daughter
validations like the most amazing little
thing in the whole world and she's like
my niece and it's amazing bro
hands up Gracie how's he doing your
hands uncle's are all traveling good
everyone's going you know what is crazy
is that October 26 which is at the end
of this month lyoto machida who's my
student is fighting it's mark mone O's
who's one of our other students and
Friends and he don't gonna be quoting
mark muñoz in the UFC and I'm in a
corner lyoto machida and they're gonna
be facing each other the first time
brothers will coach opposite each other
in a main event UFC fight so we're
looking forward to that even though it's
gonna be crazy because friends are
fighting friends and brothers are
coaching his brothers but you know you
got to do it using our Center our best
salsa tonic you know tonic for that
because he empower gym San Francisco the
best guy of all time yes my homie
beautiful let's uh let's go ahead and
we're going to a few more points before
we come to an end
tell us about you know some some brief
one story I've heard interesting that is
this true that someone came in to rob I
was your family's house was a Helios
they gave an option they said look I can
call the police or you're gonna have to
you know try expert let us experiment on
yourself yeah exactly you police or you
fight which one you want he said man you
know he said I think he said call the
police cause he hit one I think he found
out who he was dealing with but the
reality was that's how things were done
back in the days it was you know you
have a disagreement you bump into my car
and traffic okay get out you want to
call the police or you want to fight
right now in other words everything was
setting with the fight back then it was
so amazing and I kind of part of me
wishes I was born during that era
because that would be give a sense to
practice your techniques in real
situations but the other part of me
likes America where nobody fights for
dumb reasons for the most part and
everything is you know humane over here
what about Hickson it was just a little
bit all Hickson yeah but Hickson is is
you know one of the most legendary and
an accomplished members of the family in
terms of fighting and you know it was
amazing because he was not only given
that the technique of Grandmaster I know
but he was also gifted with a very
naturally strong physique and and as a
result he was able to do with jujitsu
what what most you know skinny
unathletic individuals couldn't do
and add a little bit of a physical
athleticism to it and because of that it
almost like multiplied his efficiency
times 10 and because of that he was able
to you know remain undefeated and have
some a an amazing career and be a good
exemplification of what jiu-jitsu can do
you know for a person we talked a little
bit about bullying and people go to your
University and get your DVDs and really
encourage people to do that and it's
going to really help them to prevent
their children from being the victims
aro empower them and we want to talk
about you know a lot of people nowadays
are sitting on the couch becoming couch
potatoes really motivating into this
program to get involved in martial arts
may typically Gracie Brazilian jiu-jitsu
and also dieting is so important it is
you know it does I mean you need both
you know you can be on a diet you can
still be on the couch and not gonna go
anywhere or you can get on a great
jiu-jitsu training regimen and and and
not have a good diet and you'll still
you know not getting the shape you want
so it's amazing package to be able to
embark on their jiu-jitsu journey if
you're at home get on Gracie University
calm and start those lessons and
literally people are doing it in their
living rooms on some carpet with a
brother sister mother brother father
husband at home you know and making it
happen where in addition to that though
you have to have you know a conscious
and awareness about what you're putting
in your body you know my grandfather
always said that people die through
their mouths you know through what you
eat or don't eat and and the gracie diet
is something my family's in you know
perfecting now for 80 years started by
Carlos Gracie Elias older brother my
great uncle and the Gracie diet is a
food combination diet to help facilitate
digestion to to you know ultimately
optimize health vitality energy and and
reserve the greatest amount of energy
for Georgia to practice that was the
original intent back in the 1930s and
40s was to create a diet that would make
sure that members of the family were
always optimally you know healthy and as
a result could fight anyone on a
moment's notice when they either break
into the house or they knock on the door
we have to be ready to get down yeah
amazingamazing you know for more on that
you can go to Gracie DICOM Tracy diet
comm tell us now you're also known for
doing after some of these major fights a
break down not to break dance but a
break down break the fight dad can you
do
for us let's do Gracie breakdown we'll
fight we got we got a fight we're gonna
go right now to the clip hey you started
it man making me look like a jerk at the
max so that's what you are
did you say you heard me get out of my
face but what if I don't Punk and I'll
just have to make you Punk
Here I am expecting some UFC fight and
you guys are playing Saved by the Bell
Zack Slater and and Zack Morris break it
down can you break it down as much as
I'd like to break down real fight
well we'll pretend this one is real and
of course there's a lot going on here
but initially when this is how fight
start right there's this agro energy and
we call a combative energy every
interaction has a degree of combative
energy ours is zero right now when you
have a friend in a calm setting but if
you were you know if someone came in
here was drunk and was acting a little
ridiculous it would be like 50 percent
you know combative energy even though we
weren't fighting he still is aggressing
you know creating some negative energy
and in the situation I this was a
disagreement both people agree that they
disagree and they're you know they're
getting physical they're showing that
that aggressive body posture the first
thing you want to try to do is diffuse
that through hey my friend I'm sorry you
have to step back and ultimately any
fight can be avoided if you avoid ego
and you avoid alcohol 99.999% of fight
that we're going to happen can be
avoided that's the reality so in this
situation if they would check their egos
a little bit and calm down that would be
the best thing to do however if the
fights going to go down you want to end
it as quickly as possible
and you want to end it without causing
any permanent damage so as soon as
someone pushes you and put their hands
on your chest and shoves you back they
create an opportunity for a standing arm
lock which allows you to immobilize them
very quickly and I have to go any
further into the fight and and if that
doesn't work then you can stand spin
them around push and pull on their
shoulders create a quick whip around in
which you can catch a root standing your
Innoko choke and it's so effective that
they have no choice either they take it
either they tap or they take a nap
amazing amazing I like what you said I
mean look humbleness good character
usually this is the best self defense
having a good attitude
the ego is contained self defense
against yourself yes check yourself you
don't I'm saying for your records yes
I'd like to thank you tell our audience
again how they can hook up with you and
how they can learn if they're not
actually at shirt I mean yes my friends
out there if you're interested go check
out Gracie University calm we have a
five days for you check out all the
lessons the whole curriculum and it's
really amazing actually and if you have
kids and you know you're interested in
giving them that confidence check out
Gracie kids calm and the same thing the
curriculum is online
you can have it on DVD or you can check
it out in your phone or mobile device
and it's truly remarkable because
besides the confidence the self defense
and the techniques that your child will
gain the bonding time between parent and
child is something that we've been you
know we've found to be one of the most
unique benefits of this at-home training
program because we're teach the parent
how to teach their child and in doing
that every single day for 10-15 minutes
a day in the household you really you
really connect in a way that you don't
get when you're just doing homework or
just cooking their dinner or helping
them tie their shoes it goes to a much
deeper level and and any child can do
this there's no physical prerequisite
and it's guaranteed to change your life
forever you know a child with confidence
and a child without confidence are two
different children so we just hope to
help as many families as possible
give their children the the greatest
advantage possible you know from the
get-go and head in the right direction
I'd like to thank you and please when
you see your father when you see your
uncle's Carlos Gracie jr. hands oh great
family Orion great your father your
brother give them about my best I will
send them a choke from you definitely
thank you very much thank you thank you
brother thank you that was Henner Gracie
here on the Dean show hope you got to
benefit empower your children from a
young age to have the best manners the
best character so they can be righteous
upright human beings so they don't go
out bullying anybody and they're
empowered at the same time their bully
proof so if someone is coming around to
start some trouble they can defend
themselves and they can protect
themselves and empower yourself at the
same time living right eating right
being a good human being and that's what
the Dean show is all about empowering
you to bring out the best in you to give
birth to us already inside you that
goodness that original goodness that
exists in all of us so we like to thank
the Gracie family who developed this
martial art that I myself have
tremendously benefited from and if
you're not thankful to the people you're
not thankful to your Creator the maker
of mankind and first and foremost we're
thankful to the one who's given us these
abilities to train imagine if you
couldn't block a punch throw a punch you
couldn't eat lunch with your hands you
couldn't eat lunch amazing you have to
be getting
injected through you through a -
priceless blessings that we have from
our Creator so let's be first and
foremost thankful to the maker of
mankind the one Creator who created
creation the same God that Jesus called
the people to worship Abraham Moses and
last a final message of problem a peace
be upon him they all came with the same
message worship the Creator not the
creation and do good be good and that's
what the Deen show is all about
empowering people to be the best human
beings that they can be we'll see you
next time follow us on Facebook like us
or opposite I'm sorry
like us on facebook follow us on Twitter
and tune in every week to the Deen show
until next time peace be with you